five fires for three
[Applause]
welcome to the free-throw line
[Music]
[Applause]
- Kuniko will you ever get a she
[Applause]
break-ins oh yes
[Applause]
over there
[Applause]
Yodas has written his playlist
[Applause]
anytime Bledsoe on surgical boy
we have some super fancy you know a
little bit about this shout out to spike
but this is drinking spiked 2.0 what was
some of his
talking to some of the Indian
mocking and now you have month wide open
at the top as well it's a step back
yes again the white Leonard from
downtown and the books take a timeout
later down five for seven from
three-point land
[Applause]
Jurassic Park lit by yes Drake Apophis
[Applause]
then the franchise's first we send it
down to our courtside reporter who has
not been on the air for some time
because you've been busy
well you know my my all-star break is
longer than you know I pulled up here my
Hyundai Santa Fe you're not the only one
that that's what I do know what's up
boys long time no speak is rondae
hollis-jefferson sat it away I say say
where you been honesty's I'm out here
I'm working hard you know I'm tucked
away trying to finish an album but but I
just want to just I want everybody to
just take in the fact that like Fred
vanvleet turks and caicos 10 is just
song 10 million and that I boys looking
like Frederico that's why I keep doing
this awesome they put me on TV but that
boys look like Fred of ecole well any
time you want to do the salsa dancers
let us know and ya going what's up but
let's something back in neck
the hotline bling' is out exactly
telling us straight I'm only hitting the
fret of eco 2020 oh gee Anna no be my og
going to work why don't you know looky
you've been working on your game too I
mean let me tell you what you guys have
had some runs out of the past and Jack
and I are ready anytime you guys eat not
well not anybody else to run with you
because you know we can let me let me
just talk let me just announce on here
that you have a verbal contract that you
you said you would announce our
championship games I think that's a big
deal for our league the SP oh I'm happy
to be there ya know we got it we got a
great thing going you know it's a it's
been a blessing it's uh Brock brought
all my friends you know I've been
friends with all these guys for like ten
plus years and just brought us closer
together man getting us keeping us
active as the as the ears are ticking
off the clock boys you know that means
jeez
we'll talk to your feet we don't want to
talk about scrubs on the air though
quavo beware
come on baby how dare you come on I tell
you what you hey how about this dunk
right here by the way hey Drake you know
what a little hello hello hello and the
best part about it is that typically
tipoff is very late into the evening
which is perfect for Jack that's my jam
in the morning is just perfect yeah
hundred percent
honestly it's a
it's a loose leave you know we've got it
we've got a red wine cooler I'm on a
strict read teeth I here's eight in the
spin move on the inside and a nice move
by the big man in his second year that's
a first I'll come on let's not in the
second bucket come on down to the path
and put some shots up Kyle Kyle's come
to a game at the Eppley Kyle comes to
the house and puts shots up ya know it's
it listen it's a family atmosphere
obviously like this team is family to me
these guys are always always popping in
and they're always welcome to come and
train worked out there you know I love
it
Ricky Rubio with the shot here it's good
stuff hey real quick the Toronto Raptors
yes I mean how about this 40 and 15 best
record through 55 incredible yeah it's
incredible look I'll say this it's it's
always it's always a daunting task when
you when you lose a polarizing player
like like like the one that we you know
loss after winning the championship but
these guys just have heart man like I
said we're a family and and they're and
they're just they're playing for
something you know it just proves that
it wasn't about one player it was never
about one guy one guy didn't win us a
championship you know this team warned
us this championship these guys their
heart their fight and just the fact that
they're they're all guys that are nice
to each other showing love to each other
and trust me in these unwelcoming times
you know there's been a lot of a lot of
things going on in the world right now
and it's always just a positive vibe to
be around these guys when when you when
you
you know you had dinner in the locker
room but man they're just a great group
of guys and and and their karma shines
through you know it's just it's it's
their Carmenere hard works they're just
they're winners you know with or without
with or without you know whoever decided
to take that take that pick that vermin
in flight you really should that
beautifully because that's the essence
right when you look at any good team and
gross war just that's the essence of a
good team yeah hundred percent
I mean the things you talked about
that's chemistry 100 percent in and like
you know it's like not obviously I talk
basketball all the time so you'll hear
you know you'll hear you know the I
guess unpopular popular opinion whatever
it is that you know I mean it takes a
starter to win but you realize now
watching this team that you know it's
it's often it's often just as much about
the supporting cast and by the way none
of these guys are supporting casts I
mean we've got superstars you know we
have two all-stars and so yeah man it's
great you know I mean it's a it's
incredible to watch
by the way I can't see the td3 show in
there but yeah no it's it's amazing I
just can't wait to see them in the
playoffs I don't think anything's gonna
change I think we're gonna come with the
same energy and and yeah you know I'm
just excited for everybody else in the
Eastern Conference that comes in this
building and get shook I hope all you
boys are at home watching this knowing
when you come this building you got some
little babies
Terrence Davis again the cd3 show hey
this is a building C right outside of
Memphis
come on spell Mississippi right now Matt
what do you come on it's the Mississauga
- gosh yeah yeah can I get one more
orange juice please we meet we we need
some vitamin C for dream FF here's Laur
look at this boy did someone put the
camera on this guy's tan right yes sir
get the camera on that dad oh my
goodness that boys looking rejuvenated
we had 649 to go we got Pascal checking
in we got a highlight for you here
[Applause]
that's what I came to see the td3 show
but ya know I'm looking forward to it
you know
you know I think I think we're gonna
have an incredible playoff run we
obviously always have fun of the
playoffs and
and yeah you know what like I said man
he's boys coming this building it's a
different story you know I'm saying to
get on that foul line they get a little
[ __ ] boy G trains with AK walk down have
some of this orange juice you talking
about it's good for you this vitamin C
huh yeah it is what games are coming up
does anyone know well home games do we
have oh yeah walkie Tuesday night that's
you know I'll be here for that giannis
oh yeah and then Charlotte by the way
this is the longest home sandwiches I
believe only for games and then the
Raptors head out for March your guy Mike
Budenholzer will be here Tuesday night
with the Bucks I love it
that's what I can't wait to see that's a
friends and family